[Music]
Sean Mannion and his father have always
been close but sean is preparing to
leave their home village of Ross Moke
and the country patty Mannion has
decided not to see his son off at the
airport Sean is leaving this remote
western edge of Ireland for big-city
life on the other side of the Atlantic
to Boston a traditional magnet for Irish
immigrants Sean is starting to miss Ross
smoked even before he's left I love Ross
smoke and I love living in Ireland and
everything all my friends and family
obviously here like and I play football
and soccer and whatnot but it's no life
for a young lad you can't save moving
and even if you do get ahead of yourself
something happens to the care or
something you know something goes in the
car this has to be done there there's
always something that you just can't get
back a little bit of head Shan trained
as a plumber and welder but was able to
find a permanent job after qualifying
instead he's been working on his
father's small farm and doing odd jobs
but often he's left to make ends meet on
welfare checks he won't be the first in
his family to emigrate a number of his
relatives already live in Boston his own
parents spent 20 years there but never
forgot where home was
I think the dark Easter Coast the docks
the people that's where you're born when
you're born or something back in your
mind all the time that that you want to
come back everybody want to come back
some time which half them don't never
makes it Sean will no doubt miss his
mom's freshly baked bread the family has
gathered the day before his departure
Sean is reluctant to leave but like many
other young men he's frustrated by a
lack of prospects in iron
despite his qualifications last year
alone almost 90,000 left the country
shun also pops over to the neighboring
village to say goodbye to some friends
and to get a haircut just tend to look
nice for all the Yankee girls when I get
over there
Shaun is glad that his friend Martin
will also be moving to Boston soon he's
a trained bricklayer and likewise mostly
unemployed
Lisa O'Toole has known the two of them
since school days she's sad to see so
many young people leaving Ireland seven
out of ten I've gone yeah and they're
like they've had their like second or
third year visa in Australia or America
and that's obsessed and they'll come
home Christmas every second year or
something because it kind of bored him
home any other time a number of homes in
raw smoke are already vacant and pupil
numbers at the primary school are
falling due to the low birthrate Shaun
spends his last evening in one of the
villages last remaining pubs he's talked
often with a proprietor about his plans
to emigrate Christopher is a local
history buff and says that 10,000 people
left for the US alone over the past 100
years but he says the current wave of
emigration seems bigger than any before
well they can come back whenever they
please but 15 years before you're you're
on a kind of an even keel again there's
a big hole in the ship and it's going to
take a long time to bail it out Ireland
is still struggling to recover from a
recession and there's little sign here
in raw smoke of a resurgent Celtic Tiger
a former boss of Shaun's has had to
massively downsize operations model my
baldies I used to have port
staff now I just have to and I don't
even have enough work for them moment to
myself really know but I'm just from
here
fooled and Shawn fold unbelievable views
Shaun is planning to be gone for ten
years he's packed modestly a few pairs
of pants and soccer jerseys but with no
shortage of optimism I work trying to
put two of my cousin's in case was one
of them might not be stacking right away
so hopefully I'll be working Monday
after I learn the Mannion's are
confident their only son will make it in
Boston he hopes to earn over two
thousand dollars a week
Shawn's plans to wire some of that money
back home our little consolation for his
family of course they hope he'll return
at some point in the future to that
place where the heart is home in County
Galway
[Music]